pari réussi pour patrice joly le
président du conseil départemental de la
nièvre depuis 2011
et depuis hier soir sénateurs de son
département une nouvelle étape envisagée
avec satisfaction comme une continuité
du travail accompli en faveur de la
ruralité
jeantet qui a une envie effectivement
que je puisse porter à l'échelle
nationale dans le cadre d'un mandat
parlementaire 7
cette voie et puis parallèlement à ça
effectivement une très mauvaise
perception des dernières mesures du
gouvernement qui témoignait d'une
méconnaissance des territoires ruraux la
surprise elle est venue de nadia
sollogoub la maire divers droite de nos
vies sur loire de vence de 13 voix la
sénatrice sortante anne emery du maquis
briguer un second mandat sous
l'étiquette de la république en marche
du soulagement de l'étonnement
mais c'est vrai que tout au long de la
campagne on avait c'était très difficile
de se faire une opinion les gens étaient
très partagés et surtout dans beaucoup
d'incertitudes à tous les niveaux pour
la première fois sous la vème république
la nièvre va donc envoyé une
représentante de droite au sénat avec un
second sénateur socialiste et de député
en marche le département obligera les
différentes sensibilités politiques à
collaborer
eh bien écoutez si c'est dans l'intérêt
de nos territoires justement je pense
qu'il est temps de commencer à
travailler comme ça je sentais des
organisations politiques c'est pas tout
à fait mon souci c'est surtout le fait
qu en définitive les nivernais sont sur
des valeurs de gauche c'est à dire que
le besoin d'avoir un état présent des
collectivités présentes
ça permet d'accéder à certains services
et on en manque sur le territoire
conséquence de cette élection
sénatoriale c'est maintenant le conseil
départemental qui va devoir évoluer avec
le départ de patrice joly un nouveau
président ou présidente devrait le
remplacer dans les prochains jours